the curtain is fully up now though on
the allegations against deshaun watson
and i've been very critical of tony
busby in the past and frankly
he behaved today the way he should have
behaved from the get-go
it should never have been about him it
always should have been about the
victims and it took him
three weeks to find his footing unless
unless and i don't rule this out unless
he was engaged in some sort of a
rope-a-dope strategy
which has been effective because it
seems like he draws out reactions
from deshaun watson's camp that then
get turned back against them and that's
part of what
happened today but busby was accompanied
by
several different people but the most
significant person who was there
a woman by the name of ashley solis who
was
the first one who sued watson
three weeks ago today exercising her
privilege to proceed under a pseudonym
she now has decided to make her
identity known she's spoken with police
we know who she is and she spoke today
reading from a statement during that
press conference here is some of what
ashley
solis had to say i was afraid
i'm not afraid anymore do exist
i'm here to take pass take back the
power
and take back control i am a survivor of
assault and harassment
the sean watson is my sculpture and my
harvester
desean watson assaulted and harassed me
on march 30
2020 in my own home
doing what i have most massage therapy
there was plenty more there and we have
a story at pft with some
other quotes from ashley solis and
when you hear the story told and again
these are allegations desean watson is
entitled to all of his rights
civil justice criminal justice whatever
when the person
attaches her name to it face voice tells
the story
it it takes on a far different
vibe a far different feeling a far
different level of gravity
than when it is just the lawyer who is
having the press conference and talking
in the way that lawyers tend to talk
so i think this did
get everyone's attention who's been
paying attention to the story it should
have gotten everyone's attention
and it definitely should get the
attention of deshaun watson and the
people advising him because
to me shireen even though it's only been
three weeks it feels like it's been
around a lot
longer than that today is the day that
it became
extremely serious as it relates to
individuals who are pursuing justice
through the civil system and also now
some of them through the criminal system
against desean watson
you know in his career mike deshawn
watson has 27 losses including two in
the postseason perhaps the biggest of
that
is against the chiefs in the postseason
two years ago
this today was the biggest loss for
desean watson
i don't know how much of that statement
that ashley solis
wrote herself it doesn't matter it was
powerful it was compelling it was an
emotional
if i'm sitting on that jury she was
completely believable to me
and when she kept saying i'm ashley
solis remember the name
i still have chills and he has a huge
uphill battle
if if he didn't do this i don't know how
you you proved that you didn't do it
based on on what she said today i i just
thought it was extremely powerful mike
and and she was believable i thought
and and she is one of 22. tony busby
said there are five others that they
evaluated and thought they could not
make out a case on their behalf
the problem was from busby's perspective
and this was the reaction of somebody
trying to be
open-minded and fair to all sides
involved all parties involved
as more and more individuals sued under
the jane doe pseudonym and they were all
represented by tony busby and busby was
doing the things he was doing the antics
he was engaged
and that made him the lightning rod for
controversy and criticism
it was just getting to a point where
where the circumstances cried out for
more and
again it's possible he is a next level
genius and this was the way he always
intended it to go but this is the way it
always should have been
it should be the individual and it's not
something that
we should expect someone to do i think
part of what
busby also tried to do today through
other individuals who were present and
spoke briefly at the press conference
get people
to understand why individuals don't go
immediately to the authorities why they
choose the civil courts
why they don't want to attach their
names and faces because you do
open yourself up to the the
the criticism the reaction the
negativity
that necessarily flows from anything
like this in
anything that goes on in today's climate
where
you can be spoken to via social media
in a very direct and open and hostile
way
she became the first to decide to speak
in her voice present at the press
conference
another individual named lauren baxley
has allowed herself to be disclosed
she wrote a letter to deshaun watson
that was read by
one of tony busby's colleagues and one
of the things busby said near the end
hey this may prompt some of the other
individuals who are suing deshaun watson
to do the same
their strength in numbers you see that
if one comes forward
you see what the reaction is and you
realize it's okay and it actually may be
part of the healing process
for the people who believe they've been
through this kind of trauma so
there could be more and all it takes is
one
that's the thing all it takes is one and
i found ashley solis credible i found it
compelling
and it humanizes allegations that
otherwise had been made
anonymously to the point where that was
one of rusty harden's
top arguments shireen on behalf of
deshaun watson
and it seemed to be working to a certain
extent when you release
18 statements from massage therapists on
the record with their names
it juxtaposes against 22
where you don't know who any of them are
and
it it does allow for to the extent that
harden's trying to represent watson it
does allow for that push back who are
these people who are these people
and i think at a certain level today
busby's unspoken
message to rusty hardin and desean
watson was be careful what you wish for
yeah mike before today tony busby
was the face of these lawsuits he was
the name behind these lawsuits
there were no other names there were no
other faces
today we got a face and we got a name
and she said my name is ashley solis
remember the name and i think that
humanized it it it put
everything in perspective that that
these lawsuits are about
and i just thought it was huge um and
and how you
defend against that you're the lawyer
but but i don't know
now what your next step is if you're
rusty hardened because
to me this has become very problematic
for them because we have names two names
at least and we have faces and as you
said it only takes
to prove one of these right and and he's
in a world of hurt
you said yesterday mike that we have to
acknowledge at least that there's a
possibility that deshawn watson will
never play again in the nfl
yesterday i was thinking after you said
that i'm saying yeah okay
yeah we have to acknowledge it but
there's no possible way everybody gets a
second chance in the nfl
after hearing what i heard today i think
there's a very real possibility that
desean watson never plays another down
in the nfl yeah i i agree with you
shireen and again this is just the first
of 22 stories that eventually will be
told
in civil court potentially in criminal
court depending upon whether and to what
extent
a prosecutor goes forward but the reason
i said what i said yesterday
even though the standard of proof is
extremely high in criminal court proof
beyond a reasonable doubt we saw
26 years ago what that means in the
context of o.j
simpson how difficult it can be to avoid
creating
any amount of reasonable doubt that
would
avoid a conviction but if
ashley solis tells a compelling story
to a prosecutor and that prosecutor
decides i'll just let
her tell her story i'll let her tell her
story where's the reasonable doubt in
her story now
that story will be subject to rigorous
cross-examination that's part of the
rite of confrontation that every
criminal defendant has
but if you believe that that story will
come out of
that rigorous cross-examination
unscathed and then deshaun watson
exercises his fifth amendment right to
not testify
maybe you have overcome the very high
standard of proof beyond a reasonable
doubt and that's when
desean watson has to worry about not
playing not because the league has given
him a lifetime ban
but because for the remainder of his
life that he otherwise would be young
enough and healthy enough to play
football
he's going to be behind bars depending
upon some of these claims now
the ashley solis claims i i don't know
and i haven't researched the texas laws
as to what level of crime misdemeanor
felony etc
some of the allegations made in the 22
lawsuits
if made in a criminal setting if
ultimately accepted by a jury
if regarded as being sufficient proof
beyond a reasonable doubt of criminal
misconduct
could result in lengthy prison stays for
deshaun watts and that's why i said what
i said we just don't know at this point
and now for the first time
there is that human element other than
the lawyer
which never is regarded as the human
element after practicing for 18 years i
can
i can acknowledge that we're not the
people who are directly involved
we have a job to do when you hear from
the people directly involved shireen
that's when
it all changes and i think that for the
league
for the texans for deshaun watson
for everyone involved it all changed
today
and i hope that everyone paying
attention to the story
will watch the press conference it's
readily available on youtube
watch it it's worth your time to the
extent that you're going to have any
reaction or any thought or any
discussion
privately publicly wherever you need to
be informed and you need to have that
human reaction i think we all had when
we heard her story
and it almost yeah and look we're going
to talk we're going to talk later i'm
sorry just
let me add one thing we're going to talk
later about the initial reaction
from rusty hardin but thinking about
this now as we talk it through
it almost compels desean watson
to tell his story publicly now that's
the only way
that this even gets back to a point
where we feel like it's it's it's even
again
if if that's i mean we know whatever
happened happened and somebody's gonna
figure out what happened
but i feel like from the standpoint of
how we all have reacted reasonably to
what we heard today
i feel like we need to hear from deshaun
watson and see him and hear his story
in order to assess what
we are expected to or able to process
and believe at this point if that makes
any sense at all
it does mike and you go back to to what
rusty harden
put out last week from the women who
spoke
on the record they didn't dispute much
of what these other women are saying
happen right i mean
we we know i mean they they've confirmed
that he had a ton of massages from
different people
some of them found off of instagram some
of them
were recommended from other people
whatever but
that those statements to me confirm much
of what
we've heard from these women who were
actually suing deshaun watson now
whether they had different
experiences or whatever the case may be
as you have said repeatedly all 40 of
these women i think that's the number
now i keep forgetting the numbers
probably over 40 now i think it's 42
possibly now
but all of these women it's possible
that that they're all telling the truth
as you've said mike but that's
problematic because
you have these 22 women who are suing
him and
and now we've heard the story from them
one
thing i think is is really different
about this
you know you talked about the reason
women don't want to come forward in
these cases and it's
true i mean the criticism especially
when it's against an athlete the
criticism right the negativity the
hostile environment it puts these women
in
publicly once their name is attached
with something like this but
what's different about this is i think
texas fans many of them had
already moved on from deshawn watson
because he
wanted to be traded out of houston so
that's what's
what's different i think in this is i
don't know
how much these women are going to be
facing hostility from
texans fans that they might otherwise
have if
desean watson is absolutely beloved in
houston because he's not
and and i think now in many people's
eyes he's turned into a villain
and it's up to rusty harden and deshaun
watson to figure out
how to swing this back in their favor
and and they got a long way to go to
figure out how to do that mike
you mentioned the 18 individuals last
week who attached names to their
statements now
some of those individuals did take what
i thought were gratuitous shots at the
plaintiffs
and the credibility of their claims
without having any facts other than
he never did anything untoward or
improper
to me tony busby took aim at one
of the 18 individuals who were on the
record last week because buzzby contends
he's obtained
evidence of social media direct messages
that would undercut the version that was
provided last week let's hear from
tony busby the bee clip where he talks
about
the advent evidence that they have
compiled relating to one of the eighteen
women who spoke out last week
pacquiao one of these individuals
that was released said i've been
providing massage therapy to desean in
2018 and massaged him at least 40 times
since then
i've never had a single uncomfortable or
inappropriate experience with deshaun
that was the statement that was released
let me read to you the direct message
that this individual
sent that we now have copy of
i told you i stopped working with him
yeah why
because i was hearing too much stuff
about him messing with other people like
other therapists and estheticians he's
been doing a lot the last three or four
months
i even told his ass he needed to be
careful because they ain't getting
around
i just hope don't nobody call me to
question me
that's two different stories
that's definitely two different stories
and based upon the statements that were
issued last week he was quoting from
an individual named jazz brooks and
she will be hearing from somebody
houston police
tony busby someone serving her a
subpoena
at some point she's going to have some
questions to answer about
what she said in that direct message
assuming that
that what tony busby's telling us is 100
accurate i don't want
to just treat it as gospel truth but i
doubt that he would have been making
those statements
in an open forum today sharing if he
wasn't pretty damn certain
that they have the messages from this
same
person saying those things so yeah he
didn't do it to me
but somebody who's in the massage
therapy industry
hearing about it to the point where she
said something to him about it he better
watch himself
and and you know that that's the flip
side of this problem
when you go out and find 18 people who
are
supporting your cause you better be damn
sure
that all 18 of those people are going to
be able to withstand rigorous
questioning because if tony busby can
start flipping them
into witnesses for him that's when you
got
an even larger problem than you had
going in
yeah no question about it mike and and
we've seen
presumably one of the 18 flips so you
know they're going to be digging into
the other 17 to figure out
when and where and why and how and
exactly what happened so
there's there's going to be this thing's
going to drag out for a long time mike
and it's not going to end anytime soon
and it's desean watson
is going to face a lot more pressure in
this over the next few months and
it's getting hotter and hotter by the
day and
if you're a lawyer mike what's your next
move if you did is it desean watson
telling his
his story i i don't know i really don't
we're gonna
i want to have a little bit of a chance
to process the rusty hardened statement
before we talk about it after our first
break
i i have a feeling that the statement
that was issued by rusty harden is
probably not something i would have done
i mean my feeling for the last two weeks
has been you need to find a way to
resolve these matters to the
satisfaction of
everyone involved so the individuals
feel like they've been heard
desean watson feels like he's had a
chance to be heard
the end result is satisfactory to
everyone involved it may be too late for
that
now today may be the day that the bridge
was crossed and
these cases just have to play themselves
out for a while there may be an
appropriate time to try to resolve
one more or all of the cases later but
that
look anything you say cannon will be
used against you that's just not the
miranda warnings that's reality anything
a defendant in a civil case or a
criminal case says publicly
those words can be repeated in court you
say it privately
those words can be repeated in court
hearsay you know if you know anything
about here say well i said it out of
court well it doesn't matter if it's the
person who's accused if the person who's
sued
the person who's on trial anything they
say anywhere can be used against them so
if he would
give a press conference everything he
says there could be picked apart and
used against him later in a search for
inconsistencies lawyers are always
looking for inconsistencies
because the existence of inconsistencies
will demean the credibility
of the person who is telling the story
and that that's a little
glimmer of what we're going to talk
about as it relates to hardened
statement the search for inconsistencies
and the stories
that are told before we get to that
though the nfl's comment
on this matter we reached out to them
immediately after the
press conference ended said brian
mccarthy nfl spokesman the allegations
are deeply disturbing and we take these
issues very seriously immediately
following news of the first allegations
last month
as has been reported we initiated an
investigation under the nfl's personal
conduct policy we're continuing
to closely monitor all developments in
the matter you may recall busby
actually posted on social media the
letter that he got from lisa friel who's
in charge of these
issues these matters these
investigations for the nfl
and we're told that the league has been
in contact with busby
and the request from the league was to
to have cooperation
from these individuals so if ashley
solis tells her
story to lisa freya or anyone else at
the nfl if these other individuals tell
their story
to the nfl that increases the likelihood
that the nfl will take action and
frankly shireen based upon today's
developments
i think there's no way the league can
avoid putting deshaun watson on the
commissioner exempt list
paid leave and usually the league would
say in the offseason there's nothing to
there's nothing to put him on paid leave
from there's not there's no football
going on
let's wait until we have to do it i
think this is and it's only been around
seven years this concept of paid leave
i think this is the the first occasion
where
the off-season issue has gotten so
significant
that that they just need to do it now so
they send a message to
anyone who's paying attention that they
are engaged and they get it
yeah he's not getting paid for anything
right now like they only get paid during
the season so he's not getting paid
but i do think it sends a message mike
like you said i think it's important for
the nfl to do this to put him on the
commissioner exempt list
and and he'll stay on there until they
decide he's coming off which probably
means when the investigation over
and i find it highly likely that he's
not going to play during 2021. i just
don't think that's going to be possible
so he'll probably remain on that list
for the entire season
as he should based on this unless he can
somehow get this cleared up
uh in some way before the start of the
season which just doesn't seem possible
and i can't imagine that happening i
just can't imagine it happening and
you know i'll leave it for another time
to talk about the financial
ramifications of the nfl doing
something now versus doing something
later but
i just think from the standpoint of
what's right and what's wrong and
in order to send a message to everyone
out there
who regards these issues as important as
we all should
i i just think taking the position of
it's not football season so there's
nothing for us to do
i don't think that's going to fly and i
think they are going to need to do
something sooner rather than later as it
relates to sean watson
lauren baxley is the other individual
who became known to us today she was not
ready to
meet reporters and i can imagine how
intimidating it must be to be in that
setting
and speaking and being scrutinized and
being studied and then it ends up on
youtube and social media she wrote a
letter that was provided to
tony busby and he had one of his
colleagues read
the letter during the press conference
here's some of what lauren baxley had to
say
via one of the lawyers working for the
busby law firm
how can such a good man do such terrible
things
and with frequency and total disregard
for his abuse victims
you are not a good man
anything good that you have done is
poisoned by your true nature
maybe you suffered abuse yourself in the
past and maybe you have genuinely
attempted to convince
yourself as much as us your victims and
the general public that you are without
fault
maybe you need intensive and
professional long-term help
but that does not humanize you or the
terrors you have inflicted upon
countless powerless women
i have written this upon the
recommendation of my trauma therapist
to forgive myself for not speaking up
sooner
to forgive myself for not being braver
but i've also written this so that you
can know without excuse or justification
that you have deeply and irreversibly
brought terror to me and others
again that was not lauren baxley but
that was her letter to deshaun watson
that she has written as part of her
part of that reminded me one of the
comments from ashley solis that really
resonated with me when she
said we were all deceived into thinking
desean watson was a good guy and
unfortunately we know that good guys
can do terrible things so to summarize
two individuals now of the 22 have made
their names
known whether that results in more
remains to be seen shireen
but everything changes once we
see the names once we
hear the words directly from the
individuals and in the case of ashley
solis once we have an opportunity
to to hear her deliver her story about
what occurred
and we're up to two right criminal who
have filed criminal charges
uh away from tony busby tony busby
hasn't done it but two women have filed
criminal charges right with the houston
police department as well mike
ashley solis went to the police
without busbees involved remember there
was that weird angle last week that
busby was
coming up with a bizarre reason for not
going to the houston police and
that that was his biggest misstep of the
last three weeks because that was not
credible it made no
sense and and it and it set the stage
for the attack that he
ended up enduring from rusty harden in
the court of public opinion
but ashley solis another individual
maybe one more have spoken to police
so far and justice can be pursued
in two primary ways criminal and civil
and these individuals have every right
within the appropriate statute of
limitations to wait
and file suit it's two years in most
jurisdictions for something like this
you can wait all the way up until the
two-year anniversary and then file suit
and that doesn't say anything about
whether your case has merit or doesn't
and then the criminal side is something
else that can be pursued and that's
what's happening now
on the civil side this is where it gets
interesting as it relates to the texans
and potentially expensive as it relates
to the texans
because when busby had a chance to speak
today
he and and good lawyers know how to just
sprinkle
the ideas out there and hope that people
in the media will catch on to what it is
that they're saying
i think busby shireen is going to
explore very carefully
whether and to what extent the texans
knew
or should have known that watson was
engaging in
inappropriate conduct via this vast
array of
private massages when he had at his
disposal
a massage anytime he wanted one for
sports reasons
from the texans facility and
busby said that there were referrals to
massage therapists made by members of
the texans organization
there was equipment that was used by
desean watson
and busby planted the seed
that that and raised the very important
question
at what point as an organization do you
have an obligation to ask questions
about what's going on here here's some
of busby on that point
packet number two and these are all
arranged that way and we'll put them
online that way as well
package number two is where desean
watson reaches out to a woman
in atlanta georgia
while he's in houston hear what i'm
saying he reaches out to a woman via
direct message on instagram
who's located in atlanta georgia he does
this while he's in houston
he asked her for a massage he tells her
he'll fly her in
he buys her a plane ticket he arranges
for her uber
from the airport he ubers her to the
houstonian
she says i don't have a table i'm not
bringing a table with him he says i'll
borrow one from the team
he borrows a table from the houston
texans
he does this many different times in
these massage
instances in some cases he asks them can
you just massage me on the bed
when they insist on a table he borrows
it from the houston texas
in some of these instances we know that
it was personnel from the houston texans
who made the referral who helped him
arrange the massage
and again buzzby eventually said even
though he's not commenting on what the
texans do and when they knew it
you have some obligation to ask some
questions at some point as these things
are happening now what busby was also
doing there sharim
talking about bringing someone in from
georgia to
texas setting up the potential for
a violation of trafficking laws and
potential federal
criminal involvement to the extent that
there were individuals brought in
from other states by desean watson
that's another
angle and another direction this can go
and he's clearly trying
to establish that yeah
though he didn't take many questions
mike and there were only a couple at the
end but those were the two questions one
one was about trafficking and i think we
have four states now that are involved
in this
and the second question was what did the
texans know and when did they know it
and that's when he answered
he doesn't know at this point but is
going to find out two very good
questions from the houston press corps
there veteran
news reporters were there but he didn't
take a whole lot of questions but i
thought those were two very good
questions to ask at the end of that
press conference
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports